[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hi friends would
you like to hear an amazing fact with
the recent scientific advancements in
DNA and genetic research more and more
people are discovering the surprising
details of their ancestry nearly 30
million people have spent about a
hundred dollars to learn the origin of
their ancestors and to identify
potential health risks furthermore using
DNA several scientific teams including
National Geographic have mapped the
migration of mankind around the globe
evolutionists have been stunned by
reports that reveal human history is
much more recent than they expected and
Springs from either Eastern Africa or
Mesopotamia another fascinating DNA
genetic study from the Rockefeller
University and the University of Basel
Switzerland revealed that all humans are
descendants of one solitary pair of
humans that's right they determine all
humans descended from one original
couple
additionally they concluded our communal
mom and dad got together after a
catastrophic event that nearly wiped out
the human race in the same report the
researchers studied the DNA of five
million humans and animals they
discovered that nine out of every ten
animals come from the same original
parents it sounds as though science
could finally be catching up with the
Bible stay with his friends we're gonna
learn more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answer
live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions in California welcome
listening friends to Bible answers live
and if you have a Bible question and
please pick up your phone and give us a
call
exciting time for us to network together
talking about the Word of God and we
have lines open one more time that
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two and nine seven if it's easier
you can remember 800 God says that's 800
four six three seven 297 i'm doug
batchelor
my name is john ross and good evening
France and pastor Doug let's start the
program with prayer dear father we thank
you that we able to open up your word
this evening and study we ask your
blessing upon this program wherever the
folks might be or listening be with us
here in the studio as well
leaders loading to a clearer and full
understanding of what the Bible says in
Jesus name Amen amen
well pastor you open up the program
talking about something that well the
Bible talks about it that all mankind
humanity came from a man and a woman
Adam and Eve now of course the
scientific research doesn't give us a
name but they do tell us it looks like
all human beings according to their
genetic research came from one man and
one woman yeah and you know what was
interesting is you know initially we
would think well that must be Adam and
Eve but then they said one man and woman
that following a catastrophic event I
don't know how they determine that but
it would also be true then of Adam's
rather or Noah and his wife and they
said that you know they're there looking
back at the evidence geologically also
of the catastrophe and they were shocked
and how recent it is you know they
thought that you know the first humans
showed up about a million million and a
half years ago now they're coming up
with numbers a hundred sixty thousand
years now I don't believe it's that long
I'm just saying they were shocked they
just carved you know nine hundred
thousand years off their estimate said
oh wow how could we be that wrong so of
course we know that if they keep
studying they're gonna find out it's
even shorter than that but we have a
free offer people want to know something
about
what the Bible says about creation and
science support of that a book free off
this evening is called how evolution
flunked the science test we'll be able
to send this to anyone who calls an ass
you can ask to the book about how
evolution flanked the science test and
I'm gonna call these eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
the resource phone line you can just ask
for our free offer tonight how evolution
flunked the science test if you have a
Bible question we have phone lines open
the number to call is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven we'll be
happy to get your program your call on
the program tonight
yeah and we should mention that we are
streaming on Facebook I think I failed
to tell you that is so you can not only
listen to the program but during this
time when so many people are hibernating
at home you can say hi to us we'll say
hi back and you'll see I'm wearing a
jacket that's because it despite what
the song says it does rain in California
Pastor Ross so he a little polar bear
physiology he doesn't get cold so all
right we're with that maybe we should go
to the phones pastor Ross all right we
got Charles listening in Florida Charles
welcome to the program hey you think
you'd pastor Ross pastor Doug my
question tonight is with the what the
whole thing with the Pope being in the
news about him wanting to become you
know president of the world is is there
a chance that you know is that like
possible of Sunday law happening and is
it possible in the next year so well I I
think I've seen snippets that have
floated around on the internet that a
world leaders the same we sort of need
some kind of centralized governing body
to orchestrate and and I seen the Pope's
name show up a few times I don't know
that the Pope's got any plans right now
being the president of the world I do
think there's precision he's been in the
news a lot more lately of course it's
Easter and it's very what's the word
surreal to see the Pope during Easter in
an empty Basilica you always see just
these mobs of people and so he started
there there
program begins like ten days before
where the Passion Week I think has begun
and so you've been in the news a lot but
one thing I think is interesting is that
people around the world and I'm
collecting I may do a program on this
this week I'm collecting a series of
quotes and newspaper headlines and world
leaders that are saying in light of
what's happened with this international
shutdown maybe maybe they say either God
or mother nature's trying to tell us
that we need to start giving the planet
arrest once a week so I think that's
interesting both I've seen it in Jewish
papers till at least two Jewish journal
so saying the world is crying out for a
Sabbath Prime Minister Quebec and mayors
and different people and religious
organizations and pastors are saying
look you know the air is cleaner the
water is cleaner families are spending
time together maybe we should start
taking the day off and so some are using
the word Sunday laws actually and these
are you know mainline papers BBC and all
kinds of people are talking about the
environment how it's gotten better and I
think this is very interesting so who
knows exactly how this is going to play
out
jesus said prophecy is best understood
looking backwards
he said when these things come to pass
then you all know so we're gonna praying
and wait and watch that's right we do
have a study guide talking about the
United States in Bible prophecy it kind
of ties in a little bit with us and the
religious connection there and we'll be
happy to send this study guide to anyone
who just call and ask the number the end
for our free resource is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
you can ask for the amazing facts study
guide called the United States in Bible
prophecy
jack is listening from California Jackie
welcome to the program is it / 2
p-ting in a community service project or
volunteering if you know to talk about
the gospel and if they restrict you yeah
great question
you know sometimes in Jackie's asking a
very valid question sometimes there are
community service programs where you can
get together and work with others in the
community to do something for common
good but because it's sponsored by the
local government they don't want you
using it to proselytize or to share your
faith now that actually those laws vary
a little bit from state to state but
whether or not you're able to directly
preach when you're involved in doing
something that is beneficial for the
community I think the Christian
sometimes should be helpful just for the
sake of being helpful even though it may
not be a platform for sharing your faith
I tell you a quick story I over the
years have picked up a lot of
hitchhikers because I used to hitchhike
a lot and I pick him up and I think okay
this guy's on this long road I'll have a
chance to do a gospel presentation and I
caught myself one time seeing a guy
hitchhiking and I thought oh he's going
to this next town he held up a sign that
said Willits which was just in two miles
away or whatever I said that's not going
to be enough time for me to give him a
gospel presentation so why will I pick
him up and then I thought well Doug
maybe he just needs a ride he doesn't
need you to preach to him so I think
that the Lord wants us to help you know
give he says expecting nothing in return
in you always want to get involved if
you can share your faith but even if you
can't you know do good whenever it's in
the your power to do it mm-hmm
thank you for your coal Jackie we've got
guy listening from Ohio guy welcome to
the program hi my question is is there
bible scripture that supports saturday
as being the same Sabbath day that Jesus
himself worshiped on since Jesus was
Jewish and he used the Hebrew calendar I
would assume which was the lunisolar
calendar at that time and how does the
new moon that has mentioned in Scripture
relates to the Sabbath if at all
yeah go ahead go ahead well I was gonna
say I know it I know that yeah I know
that the New Moon has is related to the
feast days but does it relate to the
biblical seventh-day Sabbath at all or
that's of creation okay fair enough let
me start with your first question I
think we can know with great certainty
the days of the week when what's the
Sabbath now so what we call Saturday now
is the seventh day of the week what we
call Sunday is the first day of the week
it says very clearly in the Bible that
Jesus rose the first day now keep in
mind you do not find the Roman names
anywhere in the Bible that the Bible
does not call it Sunday Monday Tuesday
it calls it first day second day third
day Friday was called the preparation
day and you know in a couple of weeks
the world's gonna be celebrating Easter
and they say Easter Sunday the day that
Jesus rose the Jews are still
celebrating the seventh day of the week
which is what we call Saturday and
Muslims know what day Friday is so all
of the major faiths in the world know
that the days have not changed since you
know before the Christian era and if you
look in the dictionary first day it'll
say Sunday or Encyclopedia seventh day
it'll say Saturday you can look in the
Bible it tells us for instance in Luke
chapter 23 and you can go to verse 55
and the women who had come with him from
Galilee followed after they observed the
tomb and how his body was laid then they
returned and prepared spices and
fragrant oils and they rested the
Sabbath according to the commandment
Jesus was he had the last supper what we
would call Thursday night and that was a
Passover meal and then he died Friday
you could say he even rested in the tomb
through the Sabbath he rose Sunday
morning the first day of the week to
continue his work as our high priest
mediating before the Father so there's
no question about that as far as the new
moon the new moons didn't always line up
with a week because there's the lunar
cycle is a little different than the
seven-day week cycle the Sabbath is
governed by the weekly cycle and not by
the lunar cycle
lunar cycl was for the months now when
you had a particular feast day sometimes
we refer to it as a Sabbath as well when
one of those feast days based upon the
moon and the cycle of the moon fell on
it could be any day of the week it could
be a wings there or Thursday
it would be considered a Sabbath when
those ceremonial Sabbath's fell on the
seventh-day Sabbath
that's what the Jews referred to as a
high Sabbath but this seventh-day
Sabbath was always there never changed
right and even in the Gospel of John I
think it calls the Passover Sabbath when
Jesus died he refers to it as that
Sabbath was a high Sabbath so hope that
helps a little bit guy we appreciate
your your question you know we do have a
study guide talking about the Sabbath
it's called the last day of history and
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who asks the number is 883 five six
seven four seven as for the study guide
called the last day of history and we'll
send that right out to you we've got
Rene listening in New Jersey Rene
welcome to the program yes thank you
pastors yes my question is exactly what
was what Jesus meant when he said father
let this cup pass for me was the
accident not to die or what was he
asking and kin and about having to go to
hell for three days something like that
cannot be scripturally founded good
questions alright let's start with the
cup why did Jesus refer to this cup of
suffering that he said father let this
cup pass from me at one time James and
John with their mother one gospel says
they came another time and says they
came with her mother she said when you
enter in your glory I let my son sit on
the right and left Jesus said you don't
know what you're asking are you able to
drink the cup that I'm gonna drink is it
oh yeah Lord were able well drinking a
cup in the Bible often meant that you
had to swallow something that was bitter
and it meant that you're gonna go
through a very difficult experience it
was a figure of speech
like if you're cornered you might say
I'm up against the wall in English what
you may not literally be up against the
wall but Jesus was really taking the
sins of the world
and so on and this cup of suffering that
he was gonna drink and I think you find
I didn't do a search but there's
probably other places in the Bible where
it talks about a cup new Bible talks
about the wine of God's wrath revelation
that woman has got a couple where she's
making the nation's drunk it's a false
teaching and also you have the cup of
salvation that the Bible refers to yeah
and even Jesus when he had the Last
Supper he hands a cup to the disciples
and says this is my blood so it meant
you are receiving something and for the
disciples drinking a cup of grape juice
they were receiving the salvation from
the blood of Jesus Jesus receiving the
cup of suffering from the father he was
taking on the sins of the world
your other question was about the Oh
help preaching to the spirits in praise
well you know it doesn't really say in
the Bible that Jesus went to hell for
three days this is from 2nd Peter I
believe it is first 53:18 sorry first
Peter 3 do you want to read that page
that says for christ also suffered once
for sins the just for the unjust that he
might bring us to God being put to death
in the flesh but made alive by the
spirit by whom also he went and preached
to the spirits in prison who formerly
were disobedient when once the divine
long-suffering waited in the days of
Noah while the ark was being prepared in
that few that he's eight souls were
saved through water yeah so here it's
talking about that when when Jesus died
you know it says very clearly he was
dead he did not rise again until Sunday
morning
I know it's incomprehensible for us how
the Son of God could die but the Bible
says Christ died for our sins when it
talks about by which spirit he preached
to those in prison he is referring to
the story of Noah and if you look in
Genesis chapter 6 it tells us I believe
in verse 3 that God said my spirit will
not always strive with man so it was
through the same spirit that raised
Jesus that God preached to people back
in the days of Noah says those spirits
in prison talking about people who are
imprisoned by sin so Jesus did not go to
hell and preach to give people a second
chance
it the word hell is the same as the word
grave in the Bible anyway I hope that
you know we have that lesson on are the
dead really did yes one of the amazing
facts study guides and it's just simply
called are the dead really dead will be
able to send this to to you Rene or
anyone who would like to receive it the
number to call for that is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
after the study guide it's called on the
dead really dead Leon is listening from
Idaho Leon welcome to the program no
thank you
desert Sean and pastor Doug I have a
question concerning John 16 verse two
Jesus speaking and then also revelation
13:15
and the first part of john 16:2 jesus
said the day will come when let put you
out of the synagogues and in a sense i'm
wondering you know if this virus problem
and no groups over ten can meet together
then all the churches being closed if
that is possibly a fulfillment of that
part of that text
well let's deal with that first i do not
think that the government officials
around the world asking people to
refrain from meeting in groups including
church it's not just that they're
isolating churches neither are they
isolating christians or any one
denomination doesn't matter if you're
Muslim Jew Christian or you're at the
Moose Lodge they don't want people
getting in groups so I don't see this as
part of that what what I do think is
interesting though it does create a
precedent where the government does say
do not meet in churches and so it's sort
of has created a mindset among
Christians that Wow look how quickly
your freedoms can be taken away by
government mandate so that I think is
something that will we should always
kind of look at with a little bit of
guardedness and then you had a question
what we're going to put your volume back
up you had a question on Revelation you
said well how the second part of john
16:2 deals or jesus said that they will
come when whoever kills you will think
that they're doing god's service
and then I'm wondering if that relates
to the revelation 13:15 where it talks
about anybody who doesn't worship the
Beast and His image and obey that or you
know worship obedience about the same
thing yeah should be killed and so I'm
wondering if that is the fulfillment
also of John 16 to the latter part I
think you're right on target there
because when he says those who kill you
will think they're serving God in John
16 in Revelation it says who do not
worship the image of the Beast some
people worshipping the image of the
Beast sincerely believe that they are
serving God and so yes in the last days
when the Beast power is compelling
worship I think the only way he's going
to be able to get almost universal
support is it gonna be a lot of sincere
people you know there's a time when Paul
so Jesus even in John 16 he's
foretelling what Paul did both thought
he was serving God when he was killing
Christians right so it's happened
several times in history you know we do
have a study guide called the mark of
the beast gets right into Revelation
chapter 13 and we'll explain this
passage of Scripture we'll send it to
you just call 808 three five six seven
four seven and asked for the study guide
it's called the mark of the beast and
we'll get it to you you can read it at
the amazing facts website if you'd like
you can just go to the website amazing
facts RG sign up for the free online
Bible course next caller that we have is
Wesley listening in British Columbia
Wesley welcome to Bible answers life hi
how's it going doing well thank you
my wondering I thought what the Bible
stance is on working under the table or
shall I say tax free yeah well the Bible
stance is that believers ought to obey
the laws of the land and even though
some of the government laws are
outrageous it never looks good if a
Christian ends up in the newspaper
because they're arrested for tax evasion
then not a great witness so yeah you
know you know every now and then you
might stop and buy some strawberries on
the side of the road you won't ask the
guy if he's got a business license
but I think that as a principle
Christians want to obey the laws we you
know if Paul said render to see are even
Jesus and render diseased are the things
that are Caesar's now even if C's are
sometimes unfair right so that's a good
question yeah but we want to be you want
to be law-abiding citizens now if the
government ever asks you to violate a
biblical principle then you should obey
God rather than man thank you for your
cold waste when we're gonna go to Chris
Series in Nebraska Chris welcome to the
program hi good evening hi thanks for
calling um my question was referring to
Daniel 12 on verse 12 yeah about the
1335 and I was wondering where do you
where shall you place that yeah Daniel
12 is a is a very intriguing chapter in
the Bible we get a lot of questions on
this because you have more time
prophecies in that one chapter than any
other chapter in the Bible and you've
got three time periods there's a 1260
there's a 1290 and there's a 1335 it
says days but in Bible prophecy a day
equals a year yeah and so the way this
works out you know it's kind of hard to
fit this into three minutes
this is outlining a time of persecution
for God's people it also outlines the
birth of a revival movement near the end
of time it's talking about the
abomination that makes a desolate that
most Protestants thought was the Roman
power we agree with that that just
became a persecuting power during the
Dark Ages and that really began
politically in 508 it began when they
got military power in 538 which is 30
years later and that reaches the 1798
and 1843 I know that's gonna probably
seem garbled I you know I wish we had a
chart or something we could send you on
that well you know we do have a study
guide cold rod on time and I think that
deals with this Daniel chapter 9 he's a
508 in there I'm not sure but it's not
that's in there yeah because it comes
from the revelation perspective right
yeah if you'd like to receive that study
guide the number to call is again our
resource line 808 three five six seven
four seven you can answer the study
guide called right on time talking about
these time prophecies that we find in
Daniel thank you for your call Chris
we've got Katie listening in Maryland
Katie welcome to the program absolutely
so my question revolves around Matthew
24:29 in mark 13 24 and 25 that's when
Christ gives some signs for his return
and those include the Sun being darkened
the moon not giving light the stars
falling and a great earthquake I know
that these events occurred between you
know 1755 in 1833 my question is is
there any indication that this is a dual
prophecy and that we can expect to see
these events happen again yes yes afar
friends were listening Jesus gives some
signs where he talks about the second
coming and he talks about the the Sun
being darkened the moon turning to blood
the stars falling from heaven and and a
great earthquake as well
there all of these things have been seen
historically if from where's it 1733 to
8ya 1830 may 1980 I'll sorry 17
Elizabeth - yes Lisbon earthquake was
first then the dark day was May 1978 II
yeah and then the falling of the Stars
was 1833 right I was November 13 and
even Abraham Lincoln commented on that
some so many people thought that the
world was ending it's the biggest they
called Ally annoyed meteor shower it was
the biggest meteor shower in history and
yet you could read a newspaper from the
shooting stars for hours there's like a
blizzard so these things happened
historically showing us we're entering
the last days but I do believe they
happen in quick succession in Revelation
what chapters at chapter 16 where it
says the Sun and stars fall and as a fig
tree and the heavens depart as a scroll
relations six to ever at six yeah sorry
under the six plate yeah I six you feel
yes yeah so those things happen again in
quick succession right at the coming of
the Lord Katie and you'll find that in
pastor Ross is looking at up Revelation
chapter six I was saying sixteen because
I'm a little in order to call that list
x''k that he's first twelve Revelation
chapter six verse 12
yeah so yeah I think you're gonna see
the heavens and then we read in is it in
Luke chapter 21 he said there'll be
signs in the Sun the moon and the stars
not only historically but I think
they'll happen in quick succession just
prior to the second coming alright well
let you know what pastor Ross our
engineers telling us that probably not
fair to take another caller before our
break we need to have a break at the
bottom of the hour please do not go away
there's lines open give us a call with
your Bible questions a great time for
God's people to come together and turn
to the Word of God and find out what in
the world is going on and some of
heavens insights on these things from
God's Word so once again you want to
call with a question eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven and we'll
be back in just a couple of moments
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
and we got the phone lines light up so
we'll go to our next caller we have
lowest listening from was it lowest
listening from California Louis welcome
to the program hi thank you guys for
answering my call yeah I had a question
that deals with the subject of being
forgiven and my question is well I know
that the basic means of salvation is
that first confess our sins to God and
you repent and you ask for forgiveness
and then you accept by faith that you
are indeed forgiven by God now what I my
question is what do we do for actions
we've taken in the past that we're not
sure if they constitute as a sin or not
how do we know that the Holy Spirit is
truly convicting you and that we're not
just being led by our own suppositions
or we're overthinking it
well first of all the Word of God is a
great place to know the Bible gives us
some pretty basic guidelines on what is
sin in the Ten Commandments Ten
Commandments so you know they're they're
more comprehensive than most people
understand and Jesus said it's not just
the act of adultery it's you know
impurity in the mind in the heart it's
not just using God's name in vain Jesus
said let your yes be yes and your no be
no it's not just the literally murdering
people he said you know don't have anger
in your heart towards your brother so
Jesus not only showed the actions of the
law he showed the attitudes but God is
not going to try to catch you with some
unconfessed sin that you didn't know was
a sin just pray you know there's a
prayer in psalm 139
Psalm 139 verse 24 David is saying and
see if there in his search me try me see
if there is any wicked way in me and
lead me in the way everlasting so Lord
if you just pray and say Lord you know
show me my sins if there's something
that I'm not aware of I pray the Holy
Spirit will reveal that and I will
repent and confess and forsake that sin
and God will reveal it to you I've done
that before and he surprised me yes so
if you really want to know then and if
you're willing to do his will that's
what God wants more than anything your
heart if you're willing to do his will
he's not going to try to catch you in
some unknown on forsaken sin or unknown
and unconfessed sin so and sin is not
just doing evil sin is knowing to do
good and not doing it there will be
people in heaven that smoke cigars I
think the guy who wrote Amazing Grace
smoked tobacco until the day he died but
doctors recommended it back then he
didn't know if I take up the pipe or
cigars I don't think I'm gonna make it
cuz I know it's like slow suicide so you
know just say Lord show me and you fee
if you take the steps that God is
calling you to stay to take when you're
convicted of some sin he'll reveal that
to you and we've got a book on how to
live a victorious life and I'm thinking
of is it possible to live without
sinning that sometimes see like I said
this title scares people but it's really
a good book it is a good book and we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls an ass the book is called is it
possible to live without sinning I'm
giving you some practical Bible verses
that you can apply to different
situations will evaporate a similar to
anyone who asks the number is 883 five
six seven four seven Luisa is listening
in San Diego Luisa welcome to the
program thank you very much and God
bless your ministries I was reading in
the New Testament about Jesus coming
back and he had something written on his
by and you can order Lord yeah what's up
with the tat - Jesus spy anyway well
yeah you know there's several people
that yeah and you're correct
in Leviticus I forget what verse it is
it says you shall not make any cuttings
in your flesh or tattoos so you're right
the Bible says people should not be
tattooing themselves then why does it
say that the Lord has got a statement
written on his fine that's Matthew 18 is
it the Word of God and Revelation 19
Jesus coming and he has written on his
thigh king of kings and Lord of lords
now probably past that I just add to
that when you say thigh it's not talking
about on the skin but written on his
garment he's coming wearing a kingly
robe
yeah and it's king of kings and Lord of
lords it's the thigh represents victory
power strength so it's it's a symbolic
term that we find revelation he's full
of symbolism by the way in Revelation 19
the second coming Jesus described as
coming on a white horse yeah they used
to have a strange custom if you read
Abraham's servant when he went to find a
wife for Isaac Abraham said put your
hand under my flying and swear to me and
it meant that you were resting on a
person's promise so when Jesus comes and
it says Word of God it means I'm keeping
the promises of God so hope that helps a
little bit Louisa and you I know that
you'll put you know you'd really enjoy
the amazing facts Bible study course
that you can find at our website which
is simply amazing facts dot o-r-g free
Bible study course that would take you
through some of those verses next one
that we have is calling from New Jersey
Beckham welcome to the program hey how
are you guys good be on the air all
right
in Matthew 19 23 verse 24 jesus said
it's easier for a camel to go through an
IV needle than a rich man into heaven my
question is who would he be talking
about in modern day society well I think
he's talking about everybody
anyone that trusts in
wealth that doesn't feel their need
you know money sometimes has power with
it power has a tendency to corrupt
people power can lead a person to money
can you know lead a person to pride and
nothing makes us more like the devil
than pride and so the the idea of what
wealth can do to people is dangerous you
know there's another cross reference for
this verse and you can find it in mark
chapter 10 and it's verse 24 where are
the disciples after Jesus said that they
they were astonished and they said Lord
who can be saved and then Jesus
explained and he said how hard it is for
those who trust in riches to enter the
kingdom of God so the point being there
that they're putting their confidence or
they trust in their riches we can see
how quickly riches can vanish away just
what's happening right now we can see
how quickly the stock market crashes
yeah unfortunately money is very
necessary in this life yeah and it's not
a sin to have money you have a matter of
fact after Jesus shares this this verse
when you're in Luke he says this in Luke
chapter 18 and then you get to Luke 19
he talks about a very rich man who gets
saved his name is Zacchaeus and
Nicodemus the man that Jesus spoke to
when John you know he says John 3:16 he
was very wealthy and Joseph of Arimathea
that brought Jesus off the cross and
bought his gravesite it says Christ made
his grave with the rich in his death and
then you got Jobin Abraham and David and
many others but there's dangers with
wealth that people will trust in it and
the Bible says in Proverbs he that hast
it to be rich will not be without sin so
yeah people should work hard I I like
what John Wesley said Beckham he said a
Christian ought to earn all he can save
all he can and give all he can
but our object in life should not be
money or trusting in it next one of the
behave is wrecked listening from New
Jersey as well Rick
the program alright thank you for taking
my call oh I keep hearing during this
kind of virus
these flippant congregations are figured
out Louisiana I think there's one in
Tampa Bay having large congregations
continue to assemble against the
government rivers I think that I think
it's a bad testimony to the moment
they're doing this and I think it's
unbiblical and the fact that they defy
the government how do you how do you
guys deal with that that mr. Duggar well
yeah I appreciate that I I agree you
know I don't want to I don't want to
judge a person because you never know
exactly what their convictions are but
personally I think it's unwise when they
say that you know we're doing this by
faith well Jesus said that's what my
tempt the Lord you know and so for
person to say I'm going to show I've got
faith by mingling in a culture where we
know very well that you're putting
people at unnecessary risk and some may
get sick and actually die from it no one
knows exactly what those percentages are
right now but anywhere from one tenth of
one percent to one percent of people
that are exposed they could die from it
so if the government was saying churches
never meet again that'd be one thing if
they're saying if you could restrain
from meeting together and instead meet
online for a few weeks or a month until
we get through this I don't think it's a
denial of faith for Christians to
accommodate for health reasons you know
even in the Bible in Leviticus 13 in
other places it talks about sanitation
that they if a person was sick or they a
telepathy they would isolate and right
now there's this unseen bug going around
so let me give you one more perspective
on this since you asked some of these
pastors now pastor Ross and I we work
with a church denomination where all the
pastor's are on a flat salary it doesn't
matter if you've got a church with
hundred members or if you've got a
church with a thousand members they all
get paid basically the same thing
so whether the congregation meets or not
does not affect our salary whether we
the truth or not does not affect our
salary in other words some pastors are
tempted to accommodate sin in their
congregation because those sinners are
paying the offering in the plate some of
these churches that are encouraging
people you need to keep meeting those
pastors don't get paid if that church
doesn't come together or they don't get
paid as much anyway and so there's
something else happening here in some
some of the nominations the pastor's are
paid week by week and what comes in the
offering and it represents great risk
for them and I think some of them are
putting their own personal gain a head
of the congregation's health not all but
some
so thanks good question I appreciate
that Rick we've got Ron listening in
Washington Ron welcome to the program hi
hey you think huh yeah my question is
are our God inflicting or God allowing
well when it comes to the plate rested
well for instance yeah plagues in Egypt
God warned fellow first his girl
rebelled right God laid it on him
she the flood same thing but in the case
of job job had no warning and not God
allowed it while Satan to inflect oh
yeah that's kind of a good rule or
something that God will warn if he's
gonna do it himself and how my god we
made today what's happening well that's
a good you know that's a good question
I'm thinking through it as as I speak
there's no question that Satan can cause
illness he did in the book of Job as you
mentioned and then God can also send
plague we read about that in the story
of David numbering Israel it says there
was a plague and the angel of the Lord
is the one who had the sword that's not
the devil he was taking the sword of
judgment through the land that
manifested itself in a plague in the
story of David I don't know that David
particularly had warning in advance that
this might happen so you know good and
evil that Jesus said God sends the
sunshine on the rain on everybody so
there's good and bad thing
it happened sometimes the devil will
cause problems and God can turn it out
for good sometimes the Lord withdraws
his protection and allows the enemy to
bring sickness because you know maybe
people are a nation or a world is living
without God and so he says re you want
to do this on your own he pulls back his
protection and then you've got evil that
follows absolutely well thank you for
your call Ron we've got Claudio
listening from Miami Florida Claudia
welcome to the program hey Thank You
Claudio and your question tonight my
question was how can I get an alert from
the Bible from one example I feel that
I'm getting a part from my family and my
family is getting a parent
apart from me when when we both ways
we're feeling angry and different times
how can I approach to them in in a
better time good question
you know I can't overstate how important
it is to pray and for you to say to the
Lord what you just shared with us to you
know get on your knees and humble
yourself and say Lord I'm feeling that
there's a barrier in my family and
change my heart if there's anything I
can do to be more humble and more like
Jesus to get along sometimes there's
there's anger and disagreements and
families because people have heard each
other and you can't change another
person but all you can do is change
yourself and say if there's something I
can apologize for by all means do it
even if you're not sure just say if I've
done anything to hurt you whether it's
your children or your spouse and and you
know the Lord wants us to be reconciled
and as we do that and we humble
ourselves then gives us his spirit he
brings his spirit into the family and it
can bring an attitude of reconciliation
so you know I think that's a very
important principle
cláudio that so we can pray together you
know someone once said the family that
prays together stays together
and then you know offer to pray with the
family members that are having some
anger and animosity
all right good question we do have a
free book we'll send you on the subject
of Prayer
it's called teach us to pray and the
number to call for that is our resource
line 808 three five six seven four seven
and again just answer the book called
teach us to pray we have literally
listening from Florida Lily welcome to
the program hi my question is which
Bible Commentary do you recommend and
why well thank you in and pastor Ross
may have a little different answer than
me there's a lot of free Bible
commentaries online personally one that
I enjoy is called East sword you can
actually download it for free and
whenever you click on a verse you can
download a number of the old you can
download hundreds of commentaries some
you pay for but I download the free ones
I guess I'm cheap but I like the old
ones that are public domain and they've
got commentators like Matthew Henry Adam
Clarke John Gill John Wesley and a
number of others and I love what Matthew
Henry just you know these these people I
know I'm gonna see him in heaven when I
read their commentaries they knew the
Word of God they had no computers back
then and they had vast vast passages of
scripture memorized so I like some of
the ancient commentaries and I don't
know and you know there's also resources
you can have we use I use the Strong's
Concordance where you can actually click
on a word in the Bible and we'll give
you the the definition of the Hebrew
word and it'll also show you where else
that word has been used so that's also a
free resource that's available that you
can use for their Bible study and even a
sword you can click on the King James
any word it'll give it to you in Greek
in Hebrew mm-hmm and so works for the
strong so that's yeah it's a really
great tool well thank you for your Cola
next quality is Emmanuel from Ghana
Africa Emmanuel good evening yeah I want
to know when provision
plus for some people because when I know
we on the antenna and them publishing is
going on so I want to know him for this
you know oculus
alright good question when does the
Bible say probation closes now first of
all the idea probation closing some of
you might wonder what does that mean
well the whole world is sinned or under
a death penalty and it's only by the
grace of God that anybody is alive even
the sinners who don't know Jesus are
alive by His grace through the sacrifice
of Christ Jesus bought them probationary
time to change their minds and accept
him and get a change of heart
but when a person dies if they die
unsaved their probation closes some
people their probation closes they
grieve away the Holy Spirit before they
die in the case of Noah the Ark door was
closed seven days before the rain began
they grieved away the Holy Spirit and
those people outside the ark their
probation closed when King Saul went to
the Witch of Endor his probation closed
even though he lived you know maybe
another day before the battle with the
Philistines when Judas walked out of the
upper room it says Satan entered him
Jesus never heard the voice of the Holy
Spirit again he ultimately hung himself
and King Saul I should add fell on his
sword so you know there's some cases in
the Bible of people that grieved away
the Holy Spirit their probation closed
and the Holy Spirit was withdrawn when
will probation closed for the whole
world prior to the Second Coming just
before the seven plagues are poured out
which I still think we have a little
time before that's going to happen
because there needs to be a revival in
the church you're gonna see a big what
they call revelation 18 that angel with
a loud voice proclaiming the good news
around the globe that still needs to
happen
maybe this virus crisis will be the
catalyst for a great revival matter of
fact maybe I can mention right now
pastor Rawson wasn't thinking of it but
here at amazing facts we're going to
begin a revival called the new heart
it'll be streaming from the Doug
Batchelor Facebook page the amazing
facts Facebook page but
in April 10 that's next Friday evenings
7 o'clock and that specific time every
night through the Easter week we're
gonna be meeting at 7 o'clock and be
talking about conversion and the new
heart so please join us next Friday
night here on this channel
matter of fact we may actually stream in
the new heart revival series during
Bible answers lie I'm looking at pastor
Ross he's going away oh that's good
but we're gonna try and take some
questions during that time as well yeah
excellent we're looking forward to it
again that's 7 o'clock Pacific time and
it's this coming Friday evening so if
this is maybe a delayed program that
you're listening to it's gonna be on the
10th of April the 80s gonna start the
10th through the 18th so also we'll be
updating the website with more
information and amazing facts that
you're gonna learn about next caller
that we have is Deonte listening from
New York
Deonte weapons program hi um hi so my
question is is regarding the three
angels message yeah I noticed that the
first angel was given with the loud
voice and the third angel was given with
the loud voice we're not affected why is
that man I'm glad you asked
that's what I was looking at me you know
I I was reading all this a number of
years ago reading the four angels
message and I had the very same question
why is the first angel speaking with a
loud voice the third speaking with a
loud voice well if you look at the
second angels message it says Babel and
he's fallen he's fallen
and then of course the third angel talks
about the Beast and his mark and not
worshiping the mark of the beast
however the the second angels message
about babbling being fallen is a very
important message that must be given
that's why we talk about the fourth
angel in Revelation chapter 18 and you
mentioned that pastor Doug or an angel
is seen coming down from heaven it says
the earth is illuminated with the floor
and he cries mightily with a loud voice
Babylon his fall and he's falling in
essence the same message that the second
angel gave if you look at the three
angels messages not only do they
represent God's last warning message
that goes to the world but it can also
represent three phases of the movement
in the last days and according to
Revelation chapter 3
the church isn't a condition of
spiritual lukewarmness you might say
well lay the seein ISM where the message
is not being proclaimed ly as loudly as
it should be and I think that's one of
the reasons why the second angel might
not be speaking with that lot of a voice
but you do find the message going out
later because the third angel has a loud
voice and the fourth angel in revelation
18 has a loud voice we do have a study
guide talking about the three angels
messages
it's called angel messages from space
and we'll send this to you or anyone who
calls and asks the number to call again
is eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven eight three five six
seven four seven as for the study guide
called the angel messages from space the
three angels messages well I think we
have time for another call we've got
Rhonda Rhonda welcome to the program hi
how are you evening and your question
like what my question is pertaining to
revelation 7 verses 4 with the 144,000
who are the 144,000 great Rhonda now let
me tell you right now when we're done
answering your question we're gonna
offer you a free book that answers that
in more detail because I can only give
you a quick answer you find the hundred
and forty-four thousand mentioned really
twice in Revelation 7 and if you double
7 it's in Revelation 14 it says that
these are twelve thousand from the
twelve tribes of Israel
well Revelation is full of symbolism
they are not necessarily all literal
Jews because in the tribes that are
mentioned in Revelation chapter 7 it's
got a number of the ten tribes that were
carried off by the Assyrians before
Jesus time that really don't exist in
any purebred manner anymore so you're
not going to find 12,000 people from the
tribe of Manasseh and Issachar and
Zebulun but the Bible says if you are
Christ in your Abraham seat and so this
would include whether it's a Jew or
Gentile people that believe in Jesus and
the names of the hundred and forty-four
thousand actually tell the story in the
names that tell the story if the plan of
salvation
the 144,000 you know Jesus had 12
apostles that were filled with the
spirit to proclaim who he was during his
first coming the hundred and forty-four
thousand is twelve times twelve thousand
filled with the Holy Spirit in latter
rain power to prepare the world for the
second coming they are a group of people
who are leading this great revival just
like the apostles had a work they were
leading they are not the only ones saved
just like in the Upper Room it wasn't
just the apostles there were 120 in the
Upper Room so there were ten times more
there's a great multitude that is
converted under the influence of the
hundred and forty-four thousand that you
read about also in Revelation chapter
seven so this is a special group doing a
great work in the last days similar to
the work of the Apostles and leading out
in a global Proclamation and I'm looking
forward to that starting pretty soon the
free book is called who will sing the
song understanding 144,000 great book
written by pastor Doug dealing with this
subject Revelation chapter 7 and we'll
send it to anyone who calls and ask that
number again is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven well
thank you very much you know it won't be
fair to take another caller and we see
Abel and Carlos and Debbie and Robert
and crazy people who are standing by if
we did not get to your question tonight
God willing if any of us are still here
next week I think we will be will be
doing another program take a look at
amazing facts website amazing facts dot
o-r-g and you know what during this time
of crisis don't forget to support the
proclamation of the gospel just go to
amazing facts and click donate god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts Kareem was divorced
pregnant and very concerned about her
future but God saw her in her desperate
loneliness and confusion and he used a
co-worker to share an amazing fact DVD
that led Kareem to our website here at
the website she studied our life
changing free online Bible studies what
she learned there transformed her heart
and today Kareem has a lasting peace
she's baptized and part of a nurturing
church family now you friend have an
opportunity to help someone today and to
make an eternal difference for more
people like Kareem you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
will keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today to help others know Christ
and the wonderful truth that changes
hearts and it's easy to make a donation
give us a call at 877 five zero six one
seven five one the number again eight
seven seven five zero six one seven five
one or just visit give dot amazing facts
dot o-r-g or send your gift to p o-- box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight
thank you for studying the Word of God
with me today and I hope that you plan
now to join me again next week as we
discover more amazing facts from the
word of god
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWF Axio
RG and sign up for our free Bible study
course and make sure to check out our
online bookstore at AF bookstore com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books DVDs and more to help you get the
most out of God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 macing fax 0 RG did you
enjoy this program make sure to tell
your family and friends tune in next
time for more Bible answers live honest
and accurate answers to your Bible
questions
[Music]